[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
sparsity and compressed sensing and how
you can reconstruct high dimensional
signals from relatively few measurements
which is a really interesting and
powerful field of applied mathematics
and statistics that's coming out just
recently in the last few decades because
of sparsity and sparse optimization and
so what I'm going to talk about today is
kind of turning this paradigm a little
bit upside down instead of the
compressed sensing idea where you take
random measurements we're gonna ask the
question can you do better if you get to
plan where you put your measurements if
you know something about your system so
this is very much an engineering kind of
oriented idea of you know let's say I'm
not just measuring a system at random
but I know that I'm measuring the Gulf
of Mexico or I know that I'm measuring a
person's face can I use that prior
information to do a better job and to
tailor where I put those sensors to get
the most information possible okay so
just a quick recap of kind of the
compressed sensing problem and I'll
point out that this idea of targeted or
tailored sparse sensing is work done
with krithika Manohar Bing Brunton
Nathan coats and myself and you can read
about this in our article in the I
Triple E control systems magazine from
2018 ok so just to recap kind of the
compressed sensing picture you have some
high dimensional signal X this might be
a high-resolution image reshaped as a
very very tall skinny vector and we
believe if we have evidence that most of
these signals most of these images are
sparse in some transform basis some
generic basis like a Fourier transform
or a wavelet transform basis and so in
that basis we have an S vector which is
very sparse and that's the basis of all
of image compression and also the idea
of compress sensing is that when you
have a signal that's sparse in some
Universal basis you can get away with
measuring not the full megapixel image X
but a massively down sampled image Y as
long as those measurements those fewer
measurements were taken in are somehow
random
okay so if this C matrix is kind of
randomly pulling pixels from our
high-resolution image then compressed
sensing says that you can reconstruct
this unknown signal s the sparse vector
by running this this optimization
problem that's penalizing the one norm
of s so the one norm of s when you
penalize it promotes sparsity and
essentially we find the spar cyst s that
is consistent with these measurements in
Y by running this optimization so that's
standard compress sensing and this is
really good for for lots of problems for
for problems where I have you know some
random measurements of my system and it
might be a coffee cup or it might be a
picture of a mountain or a human face or
a fluid flow field or whatever this
basis sigh is rich enough to describe
basically anything you'll see and your
your image will be sparse in that basis
so this is what we think of as a
universal encoding basis sigh and this
compress sensing problem is good when
you have measurements but you don't know
kind of what system your measurements
came from it could be a coffee cup it
could be a picture of a dog it could be
a picture of a mountain this is gonna
work for reconstructing that image okay
but what if we know exactly what type of
system we're measuring I'm not measuring
anything at all in this Universal
transform basis but instead I'm
measuring something very specific like I
know I'm measuring pixels from an image
of a person's face or I know that I'm
measuring you know individual locations
in a fluid flow field so I don't need
this full n by n square matrix of all
you know Fourier coefficients or
wavelets I don't need the full wavelet
basis or the full Fourier basis if I'm
only encoding human faces or flow fields
okay and so this is the idea of tailored
sensing that we explore in this paper is
if you know what category of system
you're sensing you know that you're
sensing a particular flow field or
you're trying to measure the Gulf of
Mexico you can take data from that
system and
you can build a much much smaller
library that describes that data so this
for example could be done using the
singular value decomposition which we
talked about in Chapter one of our book
data-driven science and engineering and
there's links to the YouTube video on
the SVD so this could be a basis that is
very tailored to your specific problems
so eigen faces or eigen flow fields and
notice that it's much smaller than your
Fourier and wavelet basis because it
doesn't need to describe anything you
could possibly see all right
and in this tailored basis sigh are this
reduced basis now we get to ask the
question first of all how do random
sensors work if I just randomly pick
sensors the to measure and this can I
estimate what those coefficients are
these a coefficients know now notice
that this a vector is no longer sparse
this a vector basically tells you what
linear combination of these three
columns do I need to reconstruct my face
or my flow field and the second question
is can i optimize the sensor placement
in this C matrix to be perfectly matched
to be in some sense tailored to this
particular basis that my data is is
easily representative and so that's the
question we're asking and it turns out
that this is very very much related to
minimizing the condition number of that
little 3 by 3 theta matrix of C times
sigh okay so up here we have a big n by
n sy matrix our Universal wavelet or
Fourier basis down here we have a
tailored basis for our particular system
and now we're going to be able to not
just pick random sensors you needed
random sensors up here down here we're
gonna be able to tailor particularly
good sensor locations for this basis
based on minimizing the condition number
of theta now there's a lot of kind of
math of why that's what you want to do
for good signal reconstruction and I'll
probably talk about that that later but
for now I'm just gonna let you kind of
read more about it if you're interested
okay and so this is kind of a good
example of two tailored bassy
right so if I only was looking at flow
fields or I was only looking at human
faces I wouldn't need that big wavelet
or Fourier basis I know that I can
represent human faces very efficiently
using the singular value decomposition
in terms of a few eigenfaces now here
I've only expanded up to three in
reality you might need you know fifty or
a hundred or two hundred but it's still
much much smaller many many fewer
eigenfaces than pixels in this image
same thing with flow fields if I have
something like fluid flow past a
cylinder I know that I can get a very
faithful representation of this with
maybe three or four or five eigen flow
fields from the singular value
decomposition and each of these columns
kind of this a 1 a 2 and a 3 those flow
fields if I reshaped them those would be
my columns V 1 V 2 V 3 same thing with
these eigen faces so those form the
columns of this sorry of this I matrix
and now what we're gonna try to do now
that we know that we're only in this
library or this library we don't need to
do random sensors anymore we're gonna
tailor our sensors to do a particular
good job a particularly good job at
reconstructing these images okay
and so this is the idea this is one of
Karthika slides that she made for this
flow field example so let's say that
this is our basis SCI are tailored basis
for for this particular flow field so
here she's keeping the first five
principal components or five singular
vectors from the singular value
decomposition and what we're gonna try
to do is find the particularly good rows
to sample which correspond to these
entries in C these are basically
sampling rows of psy and of course those
also correspond to physical sampling
locations in the actual flow field every
row of this data is a particular entry
in this flow field and so this is a
really cool observation that was made by
Kritika and also by der match and goo
York and in the context of reduced order
modeling and empirical interpolation is
that if you take the QR factorization of
your SCI matrix there are so the QR
factors
you're trying to break up your your
matrix into this Q times R where Q & R
have nice properties of like upper
triangular and and orthogonal and things
like that it turns out that you have
these pivot locations so the pivoted Q R
will essentially pivot your data to have
a better condition QR factorization and
it turns out that the pivot locations in
this C transpose matrix are exactly the
best locations to sample your system at
so these are nearly optimal sensor
locations for this library you can
obtain those by looking at the pivots
from the pivoted QR factorization now
that's awesome because QR factorization
is super simple to code up and it
already exists in almost every software
package you would ever want to program
in so in MATLAB here it's essentially a
one-liner to run the pivoted QR and then
you just pull out those pivot locations
and those are your sensors I mean this
isn't pseudocode this is actual MATLAB
code and it's also similarly very easy
in Python and other languages because
the QR factorization is ubiquitous in
fact the QR factorization is how we
numerically compute the singular value
decomposition so you're already
computing this all the time even if you
didn't know it okay and there's this
cool illustration that Kritika made to
illustrate this idea that when you
essentially what you're trying to do in
this pivoted QR is you're trying to
essentially go through all of the
columns of this side transpose matrix or
all of the rows of psiy if you like and
you're looking for for the column that
has the largest two norm and then you
take that column and you gram-schmidt
out all of the other columns with
respect to that direction so you pick
the first the column with the largest
the largest magnitude and then you kind
of orthogonalize every other column with
respect to it then you look for the next
column that has the largest magnitude
and you bring it over and you
orthogonalize all of the other columns
with respect to it and you do this
repeatedly over and over and over again
this is basically what you're doing in
the QR factorization because you're just
identifying you know individual
rows or columns that have the largest
norm you're kind of factoring those out
by a gram-schmidt orthogonalization and
then you're finding the next one and the
next one and the next one in a greedy
optimization and all of those locations
those pivot locations where you found
the largest the largest row
those are your sensor locations that are
most well suited for this particular
basis and that kind of makes sense
actually because essentially what you're
doing is you're finding sensors that
have the largest to norm across all of
them all of the the kind of modes in
this library so those are our sensors
that give you a lot of information about
what different columns of SCI are doing
and then the next sensor and the next
sensor and the next sensor are giving
you kind of in order less and less
information about the variants in these
columns of sign so it kind of makes
sense I'd like you to think about this a
little bit more and kind of convince
yourself that this greedy QR pivoting
algorithm does in fact give you the kind
of a nearly optimal amount of
information about what's happening in
this basis okay and you can do this for
for your eigenfaces example so this is
kind of the original image with all
these red dots on it where the optimal
sensor locations were identified I think
in this case we had to use maybe 50 or
100 eigenfaces and so we're using 50 or
100 points that are optimized for this
basis and the QR reconstruction it
doesn't look perfect but it's it's
definitely much closer to this original
image than if you had dropped the same
amount of points randomly and tried to
to invert to solve for an image so the
QR based sensors give you a much much
better signal reconstruction even
measuring only a very few pixels
compared to to two random sensing so
this is really neat and I want to just
point out I guess I'll go back for a
moment here once you have these
measurements why let's say so we so what
we've done the kind of steps in the
operation are you collect a big library
of training data of flow fields or of
human faces
and that allows you to build this
tailored library sayare so that's step
one you collect a bunch of data and you
build sayare then you run the pivoted QR
on this matrix and that tells you the
locations that you should be using for
your measurement matrix for C it tells
you where to cents to measure your
system in space is given by C so that's
step two then you measure your system
with those sparse sensors that gives you
this little vector Y and then the last
step that would step three so then the
last step is once you have Y I know C
and I nope sigh so I know theta now I
just invert theta to solve for a and if
I have this little a vector I can
multiply it by my library and I can
reconstruct the full high dimensional
image okay so that's what we've been
doing here is essentially we use our
sparse sensors in red here we estimate
what that a coefficient was kind of the
mixture of my hundred eigenfaces that
are consistent with these hundred
measurements and then I add up those
eigen faces and that mixture and this is
three construction and this is better
than if you had done random sensors okay
so there's also this really cool
connection to polynomial interpolation
that krithika found so essentially if
you take data from some from some
function these yellow points are non
evenly spaced these are the nearly
optimal interpolant points using QR
factorization it turns out these are
related to optimal interpolation points
called fuckin'-a points and if you used
equally spaced points if you kind of did
not do this this better QR placement of
your sensors but instead you place them
uniformly you would get this ringing
kind of Gibbs phenomenon that we've
talked about before so really there's a
nice connection to classical
interpolation theory that I find really
interesting ok so there's also you know
you can apply this in lots and lots and
lots of different fields we've used this
to understand insect flights so insects
have strain sensitive neurons on their
wings and we don't think that those are
placed randomly we think that those are
to estimate certain environmental
signals of interest we've used this for
manufacturing with Boeing to to
streamline their sensing for
manufacturing we've used it for control
and you can also use it to figure out
where to drop point sensors in a system
like the ocean if you wanted to predict
its dynamics okay so just to summarize
kind of what's the big idea if you don't
know anything about what you're
measuring you need to use a universal
basis like Fourier or wavelets that's
the compressed sensing paradigm and you
need quite a few more measurements if
you're doing compressed sensing because
there's because you just have less
statistical information as a prior if I
don't know if I'm looking at a picture
of a dog or a cat or a mountain or a cup
of coffee you're gonna live up here and
you're gonna pay for that by having to
take a lot more measurements of your
system and have to work in a much larger
basis okay but if you do know what type
of sister system you're measuring so for
example you know that you're only
measuring flow fields or faces you can
get away with a much much smaller more
targeted library for example from the
SVD the singular value decomposition and
now in this targeted library you can
design optimal sensors to give you the
most information in that library okay so
I think this is an extremely powerful
idea - took us a long time to kind of
make this conceptual leap from here to
here so we you know didn't realize for a
while that this is what we actually
really want to be doing in a lot of
physical systems is targeted sensing but
again it uses a lot of the same ideas of
high dimensional geometry patterns
existing in your data and ideas of
sparsity and optimization ok so I hope
this has been interesting and I hope you
try this out in your research you can
download all of the code for this at
databook UW comm this follows Chapter
three of our new book on data-driven
science and engineering stay tuned there
will be more on kind of sensing and
sparsity and all kinds of interesting
data-driven techniques thank you